سنعود مشاهدينا الان الى ملف جورجيا حيث
تتواصل الاحتجاجات هناك ياتي ذلك رغم ان
جورجيا هي اول دوله تعرضت للاجتياح الروسي
لكن يبدو ان الحكومه الحاليه في تبليسه
اقرب الى موسكو مما مضى فرغم ان جورجيا
اعلنت نيتها الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي الا ان الحزب الحاكم هناك عمل
على تحسين علاقته بروسيا خلال الاعوام
الماضيه كما يرفض الافراج عن الرئيس
السابق ميخائيل سكتش بيلي المتهم في قضايا
فساد وهو حليف الدول الغربيه المفضل الذي
نظر اليه على انه واجهه للتصدي لنفوذ
روسيا في جمهوريات الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابقه
دعونا مشاهدينا نرجع الى الوراء قليلا
لبذور الازمه عام 2003 خرج الجورجيون
انذاك في تظاهرات لرفض النفوذ الروسي في
بلادهم نجحت الحركه والتي اطلق عليها ثوره
الورود وكانت واحده من سلسله حركات اطلقت
عليها بل اطلقت روسيا عليها اسم الثورات
الملونه التي تهدف لابعاد روسيا عن محيطها
السوفيتي انتهت الثوره بميخائيل سكتش بيلي
رئيسا لجورجيا واصبح عدو روسيا الاول
استمرت المناوشات بين روسيا وجورجيا حتى
عام 2008 حتى قررت موسكو اجتياح جورجيا من
اجل حمايه القوميه الروسيه في منطقتين
داخل جورجيا كانت هذه اول حرب في اوروبا
في القرن الحادي والعشرين حينها اظهرت
روسيا قوتها العسكريه لاول مره خارج
حدودها منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وحققت
انتصارا عسكريا واضحا
ما حدث في جورجيا يعتبر نسخه متطابقه
لازمه اخرى في جاره غير بعيده وهي شهيره
جدا الان اوكرانيا حيث ثوره اطلق عليها
اسم ثوره البرتقاليه ضد موسكو لكن روسيا
استعادت توازنها سريعا في اوكرانيا عن
طريق التحالف مع الرئيس فيكتوريا ثم بعد
ذلك قرر يانوبوفيت في 2013 تعليق اتفاقيه
الشراكه والتجاره مع الاتحاد الاوروبي في
خطوه راها المحتجون انها برعايه روسيا
لتبدا تظاهرات تحولت بعد ذلك الى اشتباكات
وفوضى وانتهت في 2014 بفراري يانوكوبيتش
الى روسيا ونجاح الجناح الاوكراني الذي
يميل الى الغرب
طبعا لم تنتهي الازمه عند هذا الحد فبدات
مرحله اخرى اجتاحت روسيا من طاقتها
وسيطرت على شبه جزيره القرب وكانت هذه
البدايه للحرب التي نشهدها حاليا لذا ما
تشهده جورجيا اليوم شهدته من قبل وشهدته
ايضا اوكرانيا ولكن التدخل العسكري
الروسيه يبدو مستبعدا جدا في الوقت الحالي
فموسكو المنهمكه في حرب اوكرانيا تنفي اي
صله لها بهذا القانون
[موسيقى]
منها ينضم الى دكتور باسل الحج جاسم
الباحث في العلاقات الروسيه الاوروبيه
والقوقاز دكتور باسل اهلا بك معنا اذا
اردنا ان نتابع ما يجري في جورجيا هل يجب
ان ننظر اليه بانه مشكله داخليه احتياجات
على قانون فقط ام الامر اكبر من ذلك خاصه
بانه المحتجين حملوا خلال هذه الاحتياجات
على بلادهم وعلم الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
هتفوا لا لقانون روسيا
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين الكرام نحن امام
ازمه داخليه بابعاد اقليميه دوليه لها
جذور ولها اسباب ايضا
تجعل تداخل هذه العوامل الداخليه
والخارجيه
تنعكس على المشهد
ويجعلنا نقارنها كما جاء في المقدمه
والتقارير التي سبقت بانها مرتبطه
بالتطورات الاقليميه وعلى وجه الخصوص في
اوكرانيا طب يعني دكتور هل يمكن القول
باننا سنكون امام اوكرانيا ثانيه هل
سيتحول الامر الى ما جرى في اوكرانيا ام
من المستبعد ذلك اقله الان في هذا التوقيت
هنا يمكن القول ان اوكرانيا هي جورجيا
الثانيه
جورجيا مرت بهذا السيناريو الان هناك قد
يكون او نكون امام بدايه لسيناريو مختلف
معروف ان جورجيا بعد التجربه تجربه عام
2008 مع روسيا وهي تجربه قاسيه دفعت ثمنها
باهضا انسلخ عنها اقليمين باتت روسيا
تعترف بانها دول مستقله الجنوبيه
وابغاديه لكنها على الرغم من كل ذلك تعمل
وتلتزم موقف حذر جدا حيال ما يجري في
اوكرانيا طب دكتور اسمح لي ان اقاطعك
لنذهب الى امام مجلس النيابي في جورجيا
لنتابع ما يجري حيث ايضا هذه الاحتياجات
ما زالت مستمره وتجددت على الرغم من
الوعود بسحب هذا القانون سينضم الي من
هناك الصحافي اسلام شلبي اسلام اهلا بك
معنا هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على التطورات
الحاصله هناك ماذا يجري امام مجلس
البرلمان هذه الاحتجاجات هل تتطور كما حصل
بالامس الى اشتباكات الامور هادئه
اهلا بكم بالعربيه
هذه اللحظه
التظاهره لهذا المساء النشيد الوطني
الجردي كما تسمعون هاي
بعد ذلك في الصباح الباكر كما قال رئيس
البرلماني
[موسيقى]
مشروع هذا القانون من جهه
الدوليه في
المؤمنات الروسيه
صعب اطلق عليه
لانه قانون كبير يهدف الى قمع الحريات
وتحميد المعارضه
ايضا غدا
كما قالت القوه المعارضه ان الاحتجاجات
مستمره رغم اعلان البرلمان انه في الثانيه
عشره ظهرا من الخلق طاقه جلسه طارئه لتحت
مشروع هذا القانون تقول هو المعارضه انه
اذا لم يتم ذلك في صباح الغد سيتم التظاهر
مره اخرى مجددا في المساء
شكرا لك من العاصمه تبليسي الصحفيه اسلام
شلبي على كل هذه المعلومات ما زلنا ايضا
نتابع هذه الصور من امام
البرلمان
جورجي هذه الاحتجاجات ما زالت مستمره كما
ذكر الان الصحفيه شلبي بانه الاحتجاجات
ستستمر حتى غد على الروم من اعلان
البرلمان بانه سيسحب هذا القانون
غدا الساعه الثانيه عشره طبعا بتوقيت
جورجيا ساذهب اليك مجددا دكتور باسل الحاج
جاسم الى اي حد تلعب الان الدوله الجورجيه
عمليه توازن بين مشاعر مواطنيها التي ترغب
بالانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
موضوع الاهداف الجيو السياسيه لجارتها
روسيا
نحن اليوم الان امام موقفين الموقف الاول
هو للحزب الحاكم الحلم الجورجي وهو يتحدث
ان هذا القانون
يسير على غرار تشريع امريكي موجود منذ
الثلاثينيات في القرن الماضي وانهم
يحاولون الموازنه او الموافق موافقه بين
القيم التقليديه والسياده مع الولاء للقيم
الاوروبيه الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال
الاطلسي بينما بالمقابل المعارضه ترى ان
هذا القانون يذكرها بقانون روسي مشابه قبل
عشر سنوات لكن الواضح اليوم ان الموقف
الجورجي الموقف الرسمي الذي يسير بحذر على
الرغم من دعمه اوكرانيا سياسيا دبلوماسيا
انسانيا
الا انه لم ينظم او يتعامل بحذر شديد مع
العقوبات الغربيه ضد روسيا لا يدعم عسكريا
اوكرانيا قد يكون هذا الموقف نعم فيه شيء
من الحساسيه للتحالف الغربي معروف انه بعد
ايام من بدء العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا قبل قرابه عام في يوم واحد تقدمت
اوكرانيا و مولدافيا بطلب الانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي الا اننا نجد اليوم
الموقف الرسمي لجورجيا لا يتماشى مع كامل
الموقف الغربي شكرا لك اعذرني دكتور باسل
وانما انتهى وقت هذه المقابله دكتور باسل
الحاج جاسم الباحث في العلاقات الروسيه
الاوروبيه والقوقاز نشكرك على المشاركه
معنا في العربيات 360